MARKUS KLUTE: All right.
So welcome back to 8.701.
So we have all ingredients
now to prepare Feynman rules
for QED.
So that's the toolkit
we need in order
to make calculations to
calculate scattering processes
and decays.
And we've already seen Feynman
rules for our toy theory.
Again, now the situation
is a little bit more
complicated, because
we can consider
the spin of
particles in addition
to their energy and momentum.
The rules' sequence of things
are very much the same.
There is, however, a few
caveats to keep in mind,
and I'll point those out.
OK.
So the very first thing is to
be very clear in our notation.
So this is an arbitrary or
generic QED Feynman diagram.
We have only pointed
out the incoming
and the outgoing lines.
There is internal lines
which I didn't mention here.
Important to note the
momentum and the directions.
The directions are arbitrary.
We just have to be
clear on them and then
treat them consistently.
All right?
So this is not different
in our previous discussion.
Then, here comes the difference.
Our external lines
either electron,
positrons, or photons.
All right?
You can-- fermions and photons,
charged fermions and photons.
So we discussed how
the solutions look
like, our spinors u and v.
And for outgoing electrons,
for outgoing particles, we have
this adjunct vector here, which
is given by u dagger gamma 0.
And similarly for the
incoming antiparticle--
v dagger gamma 0.
For the photon, we have
the polarization vectors
for incoming and
outgoing photons.
All right.
Then we have a vertex factor.
Here, now, g e is a constant
and a dimensionless property.
But we do have to
have a gamma mu here
as part of our vertex factor.
For the propagator,
our internal lines,
we have a difference between
electrons, positrons,
and photons.
And that comes from the fact
that electrons and positrons
are massive particles.
So we have vertex
vectors which now
have this 1 over
q square behavior,
or 1 over q square
minus m square behavior.
So here, you can
already see that there's
going to be a complication later
when we evaluate or integrate
over momentum--
simply the same
discussion I had before.
And we already know how to
solve this problem of infinities
by renormalizing-- by having a
cut-off and renormalizing it.
Excellent.
So the next step, then,
is very much the same.
There's no change.
We have to make sure that
there's energy and momentum
conservation, and
we enforce this
by introducing delta functions.
We have to integrate over each
and every internal momenta,
and each internal line gets one
of those integration factors.
And then after we integrate, we
are left with a delta function,
and we have to cancel
that delta function.
All right.
In our toy experiment, the
order of things didn't matter.
Everything we had in there
was scalar numbers, right?
Here we do have a little bit
more complicated problem.
So there's an
importance in the order
of which we execute things.
So what we want to do
is form fermion lines.
We just follow a fermion as we
go from the left to the right.
And then we find things
which are always of the form
an adjoint spinor, a 4-times-4
matrix, and a spinor.
And the result of that
is going to be a number.
All right?
Great.
There is one additional
complication,
is accounting for
duplications and making sure
that the sign is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm just mentioning this here.
This will become more clear
as you work through examples.
So there is an
antisymmetrization going on,
where we have to
introduce a minus
sign between different
diagrams that differ only
by the interchange or the
exchange of two incoming or two
outgoing electrons or positrons
and/or the incoming electron
with an outgoing positron.
So if you have a diagram
which is exactly the same,
but the two incoming
electrons are interchanged,
you have to add
those two diagrams.
You have to add all
matrix elements together
for recalculating amplitude.
But you have to introduce
a minus sign when
you change those two particles.
So with that, we can now
just basically calculate
whatever QED process we want.
All the tools are already here.
And what we want to do now
next, in the next video,
and also in the
recitation and homework,
is to go through a
few examples to get
a little practice with this.
There's a number of tricks
which will come in handy,
and I'll explain those
in a separate video.
They are just
mathematical tricks
which allow us to
quickly evaluate
the multiplication of spinors
and matrix elements and so on.
All right.
That's it for this video.
Again, there is going to
be another two or three
videos which deal with actually
evaluating or calculating
matrix elements.